you
[Music]
so good morning and welcome to the
private AI session let me tell you in
advance it's going to be the best
session ever
yeah it's private information so the
rest of the sessions don't know that but
so today we're going to talk about
privacy and security in AI and the
reason for that is that as AI matures
and we see it being applied in more and
more places suddenly issues of privacy
and security become a concern for
example when you work in the health
domain even in order to get the data
that you might want you actually need to
reassure different health centers that
they can share the data with you and
that might be a challenge both because
they might have legal concerns or even
competitive concerns preventing them
from sharing the data so today we're
going to hear about different aspects of
these related problems ranging from
cryptography techniques that are being
used to provide privacy in these
settings to the kind of machine learning
techniques that we want to use to solve
these kind of problems as well as see
different application and different
domains in which these needs arise our
first speaker is Christine louder
Christine is a mathematician
cryptographer research group manager a
member of the leadership team of MSR
Redmond and is a former president of the
Association for women in mathematics and
today she's going to talk about private
AI and how we bring together
cryptography and and the machine
learning to solve different applications
different tasks Thank You Ronnie so can
everyone hear me so thank you very much
for coming it's great to see such a
broad audience here it's a privilege to
get to participate in this faculty
summit focus on AI we're very pleased is
our
kind of agenda private AI which we'll
tell you about today and that the
high-level the thing that you can take
away that you can remember from this
session is is that from our point of
view this is kind of an exciting new
research area which is a combination of
kind of machine learning research and
cryptography research so that's I think
one of the most exciting things about it
is to make progress in this area we're
fundamentally combining kind of new
cryptography with new ml in some sense
and so I'm very pleased to be
participating in this session with both
Ron Gilad Bachrach who's a machine
learning researcher and rich Caruana
also machine learning researcher and
junkie Cheon has a cryptography
researcher so you're really seeing kind
of both sides of the picture and we'll
show you some demos that show you kind
of live how in action how this works to
bring the machine learning research and
the cryptography research together so ok
clicker is working so this is our
cryptography research group at MSR I
show this because I'm going to talk
about a range of projects that fit into
our private AI agenda and these projects
are all collaborations with some subset
of our group and in particular the
slides and demos I'm going to show and
want to thank Kim lino and Ronnie for
their help with these slides and demos
so
there's a distance limit on using the
clicker so the idea is is that we can
make it advances in kind of big data and
predictions using data that we collect
from from people and patients and
consumers and things like that but the
question is you think of it as kind of a
trail of breadcrumbs that we're creating
a story or predictions or predictive
models from are we at list risk of
losing our privacy in this process and
will people want to share their data so
those are kind of some of the
fundamental questions that are concerned
about and give up on the clicker so
using advanced crypto techniques there's
a number of things we can do so that's
the kind of three crypto techniques that
I'd like to talk to you two about today
our homomorphic encryption secure
multi-party computation and differential
privacy so just to kind of get an idea
of the audience could you just raise
your hand if you're familiar with these
concepts these so we've got some
cryptographers and quite a few other
people from other domains so I'll talk a
little bit about what these things are
and how we can use them to create
private AI tools to improve our ability
to provide services on people's data
okay so we're trying to apply privacy to
the entire process so what does that
really consist of so think about the
first stage which is really training
models based on data so when you're
doing that the training data is being
exposed to the entity who's building the
model for example a cloud provider and
the next stage a very fundamental stage
where potentially even more kind of
consumers and more people's data might
interact with the model is the
prediction stage so if they're a model
has been trained and now you want to
give your for example your private
genomic data so that you can
a prediction on your on your data from
from this valuable model so think about
you might want some prediction of
whether you have mutations that are
likely to lead you to having some no
disease then that that process exposes
your private data your private genomic
data to whomever is making the
prediction there's also the possibility
that over time especially in kind of a
malicious adversary setting if you had
somebody that was you know successful
successively querying a model many many
times you could also end up leaking data
from you just from using the model
leaking data about the training data so
that's another kind of risk and then a
third kind of scenario is another kind
of basically statistics which is not
exactly I'm not exactly sure if you
would call it AI but it's certainly very
common that there could be a large
amount of data that's betting aggregated
and you want to have the ability to
answer people queries about this data
you know how many people in this state
had a certain you know property that you
know have a certain characteristic that
you'd like to know about so aggregating
data and answering queries about it also
fundamentally potentially can can leak
information that can invade people's
privacy so I guess one thing I should
say before I go on is is that this
I'm not a privacy researcher in the
sense of kind of defining privacy and
this talk is not about necessarily
defining privacy but that is a huge part
of the discussion so as we go forward
with with AI and our work you know fast
evolving world I think we're going to
continue to need to have this discussion
about what you know what is privacy what
are what are the requirements and
there's a lot of great work that's been
done I've gone to many many many many
privacy conferences and people that
think about this notion does it mean
that when you for example you get your
genome sequenced that you has to like
explicitly consent
to every single way that is going to be
used can there be an ocean of people
having their data being used for one
thing you know and not for another is
there some kind of trade-off between the
societal good when the data can be used
to basically build for example powerful
models for predicting you know health
and well-being that can then be used to
benefit other people including you know
some other people in specific patient
populations so there's some notion of
you know societal good between you know
the trade-off of you sacrificing some of
your privacy weighed against the
societal good from using that
information so there are all these kind
of nuanced ethical questions and so in
my segment here I'm putting a lot of
that aside I'm just trying to say we do
have technology we have some
technological solutions that can be used
to help solve this travel and it can be
used as at least partial building blocks
in these different areas to put
safeguards in place before we go too
much forward zooming into the future
with just making everybody's data
available to everyone all the time so
that's kind of my disclaimer on we're
not solving all privacy problems that
are not even precisely defining it but
these are important building blocks that
I think that society should be aware of
so the main thing I'm going to talk
about first and if I have a little more
time I'll talk about the first and the
third scenarios when I want to focus on
this second scenario because it's
something that we can enable pretty well
today and so it's kind of an interesting
use case for our technologies so here
you should think I mentioned already the
idea of prediction so you get your you
have your genome sequence and you have
your genomic data that you're storing on
your your laptop or something and then
you find out about a new service where
some medical researchers have figured
out a model to predict whether you have
some particular disease or not and you
would like to get that prediction but
without sharing your genomic data with
the that service or that hospital or
whoever has created it so that's one
scenario but there's also you can think
of it also in
in terms of kind of an enterprise
scenario so there could be a you know a
bigger entity such as a hospital or
Cancer Research Institute or a or a
large company they could have their data
stored in the cloud and they could have
built some models that are useful to
that to them in their business let's say
and they won't might want to make these
models available for others to get
predictions maybe other partner
companies or maybe other patients or
things like that so this this model of
prediction is very flexible or there's a
lot of possibilities as to whether the
model needs to remain private or not and
you know who can get predictions and
these kinds of things so I'm going to
focus on that and if we have a little
time we'll go to the first and third
scenarios so the in the second scenario
the main technology that we're talking
about here is called homomorphic
encryption so homomorphic encryption is
just a kind of a fancy math word for a
fairly elementary idea it really what it
means is is it's a way to encrypt data
so encrypting data just kind of
transforms it into this kind of secret
way to secret package that you can only
undo if you have the key so encryption
is intended to preserve confidentiality
but it's encryption that actually can be
done in you can reverse the order of
encryption and computation so what that
means is is that you can either you have
several pieces of data let's say you
know lots of different information about
a patient and you want you're going to
do some kind of a statistical
computation on this data and you want
you're going to first encrypt the pieces
of data and then you're going to operate
on it and that will give you the same
answer is as if you had first just done
that computation locally and then
encrypted it so that's all that home
morphic encryption means so I have kind
of two different ways to describe
homomorphic encryption with pictures so
this kind of a typical mathematical way
of describing things which is like a
commutative
Grahame which basically says that you
have two pieces of information that are
private a and B and you can either
compute on that information which is
that top arrow up there and you get some
output for example a plus B or you could
encrypt that information so you could do
either one of these first and what this
commuter diagram is saying is that if
you do this if you follow these arrows
in either order you'll get the same
thing you'll get an encryption that will
decrypt to the same output which is a
plus B and the homomorphic encryption
that we want to consider here has the
property that you can you can actually
compute any circuit on the data so you
can do both addition and multiplication
which corresponds to and and or gates so
this is a very powerful tool because it
means that you can kind of compute on
encrypted data and you may say okay well
why do you want to do that so here's
another description of home or 'fuck
encryption that's usually a lot more
popular due to the picture of Homer
Simpson so I like to call this
homomorphic encryption so I can't take
credit for that joke that was actually
tweeted live during one of my talks that
we were talking about homomorphic
encryption stuff was not my idea but
anyway so the idea is is that Homer
Simpson over here looking somewhat
puzzled is our jeweler suppose you had
some gold and you wanted to have some
jewelry made from your gold so that's a
analog of doing computations so there's
something there's some resource which is
valuable the gold and then there's some
tasks to do so it's analogous to having
some data and you need to perform some
computation here's some gold and you
need to you know make some jewelry so
but you don't necessarily want to trust
your jeweler to just kind of hand over
your whole block of gold so instead what
you can do is you put the gold in a
lockbox and looking like this and the
jeweler has to work on the box through
the through the gloves and the jeweler
never gets to open the box so the
jeweler doesn't get the key to the box
that's kind of
a key point here is that they don't get
the key so the jeweler works on it they
make the jewelry the rest of the gold is
left in the box so that you know they
didn't take it and they give it back to
you and then you unlock the box when you
get it back so this is very analogous to
what we're doing with with your data
when we put it in this lock box which is
the encryption and then it can be worked
on by the cloud for example and then the
cloud can return to you from encrypted
results so that's a fundamental concept
of homomorphic encryption and the way
that we the way that we actually enable
this is some very wonderful and
beautiful mathematics now I'm not going
to spend too much time talking about the
mathematical history of this problem but
just to give you a kind of a timeline to
know a little bit about how things
evolve in cryptography we've had a
homomorphic encryption was an open
problem for about 30 years until 2009
when Craig Gentry came up with an
initial solution and since then many
many researchers have contributed to
improving and extending in this solution
and making it more practical including
our group here at Microsoft Research
who's been working on this area for
about five or six years especially
working on building robust applications
especially to kind of genomics and
health privacy issues but if you look at
the history of cryptography if you look
so in public key cryptography these
factoring based systems like RSA were
introduced in 1975 elliptic curve
cryptography in 1985 you know parings
was another big area in 2008 in each
case there was something like at least a
ten year time lag before these kind of
new mathematical problems and solutions
could be adopted by the industry and
that's just to give people time to think
about these problems start working on
them understand how hard they really are
things like that and so that's what
we're seeing today in our lattice base
cryptography which underlies these new
solutions for homomorphic encryption
were proposed you know roughly ten years
ago but the community has been doing a
lot of work on understanding the
security of these problems and actually
just last week on Thursday and Friday we
hosted a huge homomorphic encryption
standardization workshop here at
Microsoft Research to bring together the
community both industry and academia and
government parties to kind of agree on
standardizing this technology so that's
a very kind of exciting step that will
help us to provide the foundations for
industry and government and researchers
to adopt this technology more broadly
especially in health and financial
industries where there's a lot of kind
of inherent privacy issues so I'm not
going to talk too much about I'm not
going to say anymore about the
mathematics underlying this but there
are some very interesting and hard
mathematical problems that have been
around for decades which are hard
lattice problems that underlie the kind
of the security of these systems and
another nice thing about these new
lattice based systems is that they we
don't know of any quantum attacks yet so
in this era where we're thinking a lot
about post quantum cryptography we want
to have systems which are robust to an
attack by a potential quantum computer
we were very happy to have lattice based
systems that where we don't know any any
new polynomial time quantum attacks so
so what I'd like to I'd like to spend
the rest of my time showing you a few
demos of this technology kind of working
in action doing these kind of private
predictions so here at Microsoft
Research we've released a library called
the CEO library there a lot of articles
written in the technological press about
it including a nice picture of a seal
and this has been developed by our group
while many versions of it over the last
five or six years but the most recent
version was released in November 2015
recent release version 2.2 was released
in the in June and it's freely available
so you can go to our site and
download it and play around with it if
you want to so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to I'm going to show you
some demos of this technology working in
action okay you see the whole thing now
okay so this is a this is actually a
genomic prediction so let me just run it
okay so I'll run it one more time in
just a second so what we're going to do
here is we're going to predict the
flowering time of a flower we're not
using human genomic data here because
it's harder to get access to to do
experiments but we're actually using
200,000 locations on the genome of each
flower so so more than 200,000 so this
is somewhat representative of real
computation so you would want to do even
on a human genome it's reasonable to
think that you would do computations or
talk to genomics researchers could be
anywhere from 50,000 locations up to a
million locations on the human genome so
this kind of representative of the kind
of large-scale you know data that you
have to handle for genomic predictions
and here we're predicting the flowering
time for a flower the average is like
thirty seven point two days and so
what's happened is is that this genomic
information to the flower has been
encrypted and uploaded to the cloud so
what you're seeing here is the live
service running an adder including the
communication time so when I when I
click Next it's going to start doing the
computation of predicting the flowering
time and you could see in somewhere it's
usually somewhere between one and two
seconds depending on the communication
time it's predicted that the flowering
time is twenty nine point one days so
what happened was that information was
sent up to the cloud the prediction was
done the encrypted result was sent back
and then it was decrypted locally so
that's what you just saw and the one of
the things you know to keep in mind is
is that the performance of
homework encryption algorithm depends
very much on it most heavily depends on
the depths of the circuit so the more
complicated the function the the worse
the parameters are in the worse our
performance so what you see here is even
on kind of a large amount of data if the
model itself in this case was a linear
model the model is very low depth then
you'll see you know extremely good
efficiency so the next model that I want
to show you this is a really kind of an
interesting example of melding or
merging machine learning research with
cryptography research and you'll see a
little bit more about this in our next
talk from rich Caruana
so this is a model that was trained by
ron and and rich for doing pneumonia
risk prediction and here the idea is is
that a patient could come into the
hospital they have pneumonia and you
want to decide okay wait what should we
do with this person this could be very
dangerous you know this could be
life-threatening
should they be admitted to the hospital
or you know there's a lot of risks of
infection and stuff from being in the
hospital so is it better to send them
home and have them have chicken soup so
this is kind of a mortality risk
predictor and this is a model that was
built based on 46 characteristics so if
you look down in this bottom left corner
you can see there's lots of lots of
different characteristics here age not
sure if you can see it very well
diabetes asthma chronic liver disease
all these different characteristics down
in the bottom so there are kind of 46
different characteristics and what they
did was to train a model which has
actually degree for its example of these
intelligible models so this is not these
models are no longer linear not like the
previous demo but what you're seeing
here is degree 4 models and there's kind
of 46 polynomials of degree 4 which have
to be evaluated so when I press
next you'll see it being sent up to the
cloud and it's going to do the
prediction and it's going to return the
result which is kind of the mortality
likelihood from from having pneumonia so
this result was returned and if you're
kind of more over in the green area then
you're a pretty good candidate for going
home and having chicken soup and the
interesting thing is here in that time
that you saw those eight seconds what
you really saw was that we had done the
predictions for more than 4,000
different patients so each one of these
is kind of a different you see the
slider jumping around there though each
one of those is a prediction for a
different patient so we batched a lot of
requests all together so that was kind
of a debrief or model so what I wanted
to show you was kind of our most
complicated and kind of impressive
prediction tasks that we could do today
already pretty efficiently there are
lots of other models we can do as well
but this is one that we show as a as an
example of what this is called crypto
nets so it's actually it's actually a
neural net prediction that's happening
if you see down in the left hand corner
you see these handwritten ditches and
the handwritten digits are each one is a
little image in itself and each image
will be encrypted and sent up to the
cloud and in the cloud the computation
that's being done is the prediction of
what digit is this what handwritten
digit is this so this is kind of a
simple example of image processing so
it's trying to understand this image and
give back a prediction of what number is
it and so when the predictions come back
what you'll see is our confidence level
that we have actually correctly
predicted a certain a certain digit and
again this was kind of a combination of
the machine learning research expertise
coming from from Ronnie and the
cryptography of building blocks that
were able to achieve so we're able to
like slightly alter the the underlying
neural nets model the activation
function actually to make this a more
efficient process and as you can see
this was a big surprise to the community
that we could actually do deep learning
on encrypted data so this is an example
of neural nets running on encrypted data
and so the size of the digit here
indicates the confidence of the
prediction and again in that time that
you saw you saw that it took more than
80 seconds is because the model is
something that's a lot deeper than the
other ones that I showed you but you can
see we did 4,000 predictions in that
time so I'm pretty much out of time but
what I want this was kind of the key
thing that I wanted to show you were
these these predictions running live in
Azure on real data to do this kind of
tasks and doing them privately so I
think that it was a big surprise to the
community that we can already do things
like deep learning on encrypted data and
we've continued to push this forward
working on the training stage and other
things like I think I'll stop at this
point yes I was wondering for the
accuracy when you train unencrypted data
then is there any impact is the accuracy
essentially the same that's obtained if
you train on unencrypted data yes so
there's two different things you can do
one would would not affect the accuracy
at all that is if you train on encrypted
data and you use exactly the same
training model that you use on the
unencrypted data then the result will be
the same there will be no difference
however one of those things when I talk
about the kind of new research
directions sometimes we can slightly
alter the model so in this case slightly
alternating altering the activation
function and then that's part of kind of
ongoing research from both machine
learning community and ourselves as to
how these kinds of changes affect the
accuracy of the model so there can be
very small differences in accuracy and
we can even just study that on the
unencrypted data like here's all the
unencrypted data let's see if we change
our model a little bit how much it's
going to change the accuracy and then we
can run that model on the encrypted data
and then there's no change between the
accuracy thanks to the talks very
impressive you've got homomorphic
encryption running at the speed 2
reporting nonetheless I'm curious do you
have a sense of what the performance
ratio with the performance loss is when
you're going through homomorphic
encryption I mean you're giving us
absolute numbers but if you were just to
run that it's a straight computation is
it factor of 100 factor of thousand yeah
I can give you a good idea of that so
when we started working in this area
around 2011 the initial solutions
reported a loss of something like 13
orders of magnitude so like 10 to the 13
worse and so what we've been very proud
of is in our group that techniques that
we've introduced have allowed us to
bring it down to about six orders of
magnitude worse so you're still talking
about something that's taking you you
know whatever you know if it took it
took a microsecond now it's taking a
second so this isn't good in general
there's going to be applications that
are very very latency sensitive and
there will probably not tolerate at
least immediately that level of slowdown
but what we found is that for most tasks
which are first of all statistical when
we see what's actually done you know in
the industry on data statistical tasks
are very very simple for us to handle
and so the performance that we observe
could be perfectly reasonable and then
there's other tasks which are going to
be maybe like a training task which is
significantly
harder where our slowdown is you know is
considerable but yet it could tolerate
you know if you're training a model
offline we could end up achieving
performance which is which is tolerable
anyway even with six orders of magnitude
photo so it definitely doesn't come
without a cost okay thank you
we'll have to switch to the next speaker
so let's think
Christine again our next speaker is a
rich Khurana which is a senior
researcher in MSR one known figure in
the machine learning community many
contributions including this idea of
transfer learning for example and today
is going to talk about another
contribution he made about intelligible
models and this is the kind of models
you want to use usually on tasks where
you actually care about privacy and this
kind of things thanks Randy so I'm going
to talk about the importance of
transparent models in critical
applications such as healthcare and the
way this ended up in this session in
connected with this work is Randy and I
have known each other for many years
I've been doing this work for five six
seven years Randy started doing this
cryptographic work and at some point he
said you know I think there's a chance
that the kind of models that you're
training to be transparent might
actually be useful for us in the
homomorphic encryption world so that's
how the connection was made it's all
Randy's fault and one thing led to
another and now they have this cool demo
using this kind of model but I'm going
to start off talking about the
importance of the transparent models and
how I got into this and only at the end
will I tie it back to the homomorphic
encryption okay so let me start you know
maybe you got data for a million
patients you've got all the right
clinical features you train a
state-of-the-art model you get an ROC
that's unbelievable 0.95 you know so
you've trained this neural net perhaps
and now the question is is it actually
safe to go ahead and use this kind of
model on real patients you know is
having high accuracy on test data sort
of enough to trust the model well all
you really got at this point is some
sort of black box that maybe you don't
understand the insides of and you know
it's got a high arc roc on test data but
that's all you know and it's going to
turn out there are risks of using this
kind of model even if it looks like it's
a
flyer so let me tell you how I first
discovered these risks back when I was a
grad student CMU in the mid-90s was
working on this pneumonia project and
our goal was to decide if you were low
risk or high risk just as in the demo so
we you know low risk go home chicken
soup antibiotics calls in a few days if
you're not feeling better high risk
though 10% or more of the patients with
pneumonia back then died from their
pneumonia you definitely need to be in
the hospital of your high risk one of
our goals was to compare various machine
learning methods that were available at
the time to see which of them might be
best at predicting risk of patients and
I got kind of lucky the transfer neural
nets that I was developing at the time
turned out to be the most accurate model
than any of us could train them the data
so that was great you know I kind of won
the competition and then the question
arose was it you know safe for us to
consider using these on real patients
and I said you know no we should not use
the the blackbox neural net on real
patients and instead we went to the
trusted method that everybody uses you
know logistic regression when we started
talking about real patients so why did
we do that why did we intentionally not
use the most accurate model a friend who
is training a rule-based system at the
time on the same data learn the rule
that if you have a history of asthma it
lowers your chance of dying from
pneumonia okay so you don't have have to
have a lot of medical experience to
question whether that makes sense we ask
the doctors and the doctors that you
know it's probably a true pattern in the
data we consider asthma a very serious
risk for pneumonia patients so so we
give them really good care and what
you're telling us is that care is so
effective that actually they have less
chance of dying you know compared to the
rest of the population and the story is
even more complicated than this that you
know people who have a history of asthma
pay attention to how well they're
breathing
they probably noticed pneumonia symptoms
earlier they already have a doctor they
call the doctor right away they get an
appointment right away because the
doctor takes it seriously the doctor
treats them right away treats them very
well so so they're actually like
noticing the symptoms early they're
getting to care faster and they're
getting really good care when they get
there and those are all the magic things
if you have an infection like pneumonia
so so it's not a surprise that in fact
the asthmatic patients who now have
pneumonia have a
chance of surviving now we assume if a
rule-based learning system running on
the data learn this pattern then the
neural net probably learned it as well
so this kind of problem is sitting in
the in the neural net and we're thinking
of using these models to try to decide
who we should admit or not admit to the
hospital right so you can see that this
could be dangerous for asthmatics right
it would think that they're low-risk
that they maybe don't need
hospitalization the exact opposite of
the care that they've been getting which
makes them lower risk so this would be a
bad thing potentially Prismatic and I
said you know we're not going to use the
model not because of the asthma problem
now that you tell me about the asthma
problem I'm a smart guy I can probably
fix the neural net and make this problem
go away I said what terrifies me is what
else the neural net might have learned
that's similarly wrong but the
rule-based system didn't learn it so I
don't know that I have this other
problem that I need to go fix and I said
that's why we won't use a blackbox model
in these patients so the key to
discovering this asthma thing was that
some transparent intelligible model
learn something and we just sort of
looked at that model it's like wow that
looks really questionable we should
investigate that further
okay so just lessons before we go on to
what we're doing about this it's always
going to be risky to use data for
purposes for which it was not collected
and that's the world we find ourselves
in data is easy to collect we have tons
of data now the data was not collected
for whatever you're probably going to do
with it and it turns out because of that
they're going to be land mines in the
data and I'll show you some of those
landmines beyond this asthma problem
note by the way we can't have the right
data for asthma it's not ethical to send
half of our asthmatics home to see what
happens to them if we don't put them in
the hospital and give them good care so
so we can't even have the right data
that we want in many of these settings
it's much too difficult in my opinion to
try you might just say oh well you
should have recognized this problem in
the data data is complicated so we're
not going to do that we're going to set
a lower bar and instead we're just going
to try to make a model that we train on
the data be as interpreted as possible
so that's our goal and we think in
healthcare it's just often going to be
critical that you have this sort of
intelligibility and I'll mention at the
end if I have some time it's
it's exactly the same story if you're
worried about things like race bias
gender bias socioeconomic class it turns
out it's exactly the same story as the
asthma problem all right so let's jump
in all we would need now would be an
accurate model you know that's a
transparent and then we're there so
unfortunately we have this problem our
most accurate learning methods
unfortunately tend to be the least
intelligible and our most intelligible
learning methods tend to be the least
accurate on many data sets so we have
this sort of well known trade-off and
what we're looking for is something here
in the cloud which is you know both high
accuracy and high intelligibility and to
our surprise we've made some progress
for certain kinds of problems on
developing method that's up in this
corner okay we didn't really invent the
method statisticians are very smart they
invented it in the late 80s
it's called generalized additive models
let me tell you about it you've got
simple models just linear things you
know wait times a feature plus a wait
times a feature then you've got full
complexity things here which are just
some complex function of all the
features fortunately there's a space in
between this is an additive model it's a
function of a single feature plus a
function of a single feature so it's an
additive sum of functions which can be
complex multi modal functions but there
are only functions of individual
features so this is a sort of
generalization of this instead of just a
wait times a feature as a function of a
feature
turns out this is a very interesting
class of functions I'll show you an
example of that and then there's a
generalization of this this sum is the
sum of all these functions of individual
features and this sum is the sum of all
these functions of pairs of features sum
of all the triples of features so we can
now do pairwise interactions three-way
interactions what we're going to do is
restrict ourselves to just shape
functions of individual features and
some functions of a few pairwise
interactions and in fact today all I'll
talk about is this I'm not going to talk
about the pairwise interactions okay
as I said statisticians invented this
it's called generalized additive models
and there's some wonderful literature
that was done in that this is considered
sort of a classic method now there's
almost not that much research being done
on it anymore what we've done what we
brought to the table is modern machine
learning and computer horsepower so
we're going to do these models in a way
that status to
she's never dreamed of doing it and in
the process of doing that we're going to
focus on two things make them as
accurate as possible and keep the
transparency the intelligibility of the
model so that's our goal
okay I'm going to skip all the details
of how we do that so I don't want to
bore you with you
you know papers worth of detail I'm
going to just jump to the model here so
this is a term in our model this has
been pneumonia data set there are 46
features in this data set as Kristen
showed you at the bottom of the demo
this is one of the features this is age
and we're going to spend three or four
minutes going over this graph so you
really understand it so remember there
are 46 graphs just like this this is
just what it's learned for age this is
age across the bottom here all the
people in the study were adults of their
age 18 to a few people over 100 this is
a density at the bottom so you can see
most patients are sort of between 60 and
90 as you might expect so let me tell
you how to read this model so this is a
risk score these are the numbers that
Kristin showed in the demo that was the
sum that the homomorphic encryption
model was making a prediction these are
these risk scores and the way it works
is if you say have a risk of one added
to your score that kind of doubles your
chance of death so that would be a bad
thing and if you have something like a
minus one added to your score that would
be great it kind of cuts your chance of
dying in half and on this graph let's
see patients who are about 70 have a
zero added to their score that means
being 70 neither increases nor decreases
your chance of dying okay so so the
background rate is 10% if we now take
your age into account it turns out your
chance of dying is still 10% and still
we until we look at the other forty five
features and see if that raises or
lowers your risk so in the way you use
this is you go to each graph you find
your age or your blood pressure you know
partial pressure of oxygen in your blood
you look at the graph you find where you
are you read off this vertical number
you write the number down do that for
all 46 graphs add up all those numbers 1
over 1 e to the months X you got a
probability okay so this is how we get
get risk scores and again being down is
good so let's see what the model has
learned well let's see it's it's
good to be young so-so being young
apparently young is like anything under
50 so remember the model doesn't know
anything about young it doesn't know
what ages it's just learning this from
the data but apparently it thinks that
basically anybody under 50 is young as
far as pneumonia is concerned
so that's kind of nice and then risk
slowly Rises as you go past 50 to say
mid-60s okay so that's not too bad so
that's a comforting for some of us and
then risk seems to jump fairly
dramatically at about 65 66 67 68 this
would have been retirement age in the
mid 90s so the bad news is that somehow
retiring is bad for you which is
unfortunate now I guess a lot of things
happen at retirement you might change
your health care provider you might
change your insurance company your daily
activity might change you know the the
haste with which you get to health care
so that you can make that meeting on
Friday might change so so so
unfortunately your risk does go up at at
retirement and then risks Rises you know
fairly dramatically as you get older and
then there's two more interesting things
maybe three risk seems to rise at about
85 86 then it's kind of flat and then it
seems the error bars are big here but
risks maybe drops a little bit at this
like 101 so let's talk about this
there's nothing in the healthcare code
that says you should treat patients who
or say 86 different from patients who
are 84 so we don't have anything like
that in the u.s. we're pretty sure this
is purely a social effect which is
especially in the mid 90s like like
today I think you know 95 is the new 85
right right but but back in the mid 90s
85 87 80 is considered fairly old so we
think this is a sort of you know
grandpa's 86 not doing well he's already
had two courses with of antibiotics he's
very very sick perhaps we should let
Grandpa pass sorry
you don't look 86 let me tell you yeah
so so and this effect could be this
could be in the doctors opinion it could
be in the patient's own opinion it could
be in the patient's spouse's opinion and
it could be the patient's children's
opinion right right so this is probably
some combined effect of all of these
different groups and somehow there's
this round number where we somehow
considered people back in the mid 90s
who are like 85 and older to be sort of
older in a way that maybe we weren't
going to treat as aggressively if they
were very very sick so we think this is
a something that the model has detected
which is just a social effect now we
think this drop at 101 is exactly the
same thing so here I'll make you feel
better you've made it this far we're not
going to give up on your nail so let's
go for it you know 102 let's see if we
can make 102 so again we think that this
is a social effect and in fact I
wouldn't believe this given the error
bars except that we see it in multiple
data sets so we see this sort of round
number affected about 101 so we think
it's people who are sort of going for it
so okay and these are fairly small
effects right we're talking about
differences in risk of 0.1 or 0.2 so
this like changes your probability from
being 11% to 12% or from 11% to 10% but
but they're non-trivial differences now
you mentioned having good genes we think
that might be part of the explanation
for why the risk is so flat at this high
age so okay interesting thing about this
model it's just as accurate as the
neural net that we trained and yet we
just spent a couple minutes you know
sort of understanding exactly what this
model has learned we assume the neural
net has learned something very similar
inside of it but we don't know how to
get to it we don't know how to
understand it whereas this model we can
easily understand it we can find things
and we can say oh we need to look at
this we need to examine this it tells us
here we'd love to have a new variable
probably which is retirement because not
everybody
these ages so we'd love to have another
variable added to the data set if we
could we probably want to tell doctors
stop treating patients who are 86 and 87
differently than those who are 84
because there's an effect here that that
probably isn't needed and and then this
is interesting if we're going to use the
model to decide who to admit to the
hospital we don't want the model to
think that patients who are 101 are
actually less risk than patients who are
99 right so we don't want that so we
would want to fix the model so that it
most risks would continue to go flat or
maybe slowly rise up here so this model
is not only something that we can easily
it's not only very accurate but we can
look at it we can try to understand what
it's learned and then we can also try to
fix it so a doctor could fix this and
it's interesting if we fix that our
accuracy on the test set will go down
but it should go down because our
accuracy on the test that was illusory
the model is actually picking up on the
signal that we don't want to use now
it's interesting if we wanted to use
this model not to decide who to admit to
the hospital but to decide we're an
insurance company and we have to provide
money for these people then this is the
right model like we actually do want to
know that people who are 101 might live
longer because then we'll have to have
more money for their healthcare for the
for the future so if we're an insurance
provider this is the right thing the
model should do and it should know that
asthmatics have a better chance of
living right it the model should do all
those things but if we're going to use
it to decide to admit patients to the
hospital we want to get rid of the
asthma effect we want to make sure it
doesn't think asthmatics your lower risk
and therefore doesn't put them in the
hospital and we want to make sure it
thinks the people who are 101 are high
risk just like people who are 99 it's
interesting now that we have this
intelligible model it learned some other
things it learned not only that asthma
is good for you it learned that a
history of chest pain was good for you
and it learned that heart disease for
good for you in fact the heart disease
is a bigger effect than the asthma
effect so and we assume it's exactly the
same mechanism if you have a history of
chest pain or heart disease you're
paying attention to how you feel you
come down with pneumonia you notice the
symptoms earlier you call a doctor the
doctor takes it very seriously you get
in quickly and you get treatment right
away and ultimately these are all good
things for you
so so these are other things that we
would want to remove from the model so
it's good we didn't deploy that neural
net back then because presumably the
neural net learned these terrible things
as well but this model is so transparent
that we really could safely deploy this
model after fixing it right after
removing these effects and fixing the
age 101 effect but notice that the model
correctness and the data correctness
really depends on what we're going to
use the model for for an insurance
provider these are good things to keep
in the model for hospital admission
decisions these are bad things to keep
in the model so the model is neither
correct or incorrect it depends very
much on how you're going to use it and
it's very important that you you might
think you could just remove these
features train the model and then all
these problems would go away once you
know about them that's not true because
of correlation remember these asthma
heart disease things are in the label
those patients actually do live longer
those things are in the data and because
of correlation with other features the
model will do its best to learn those
effects through correlation with other
features and now what will happen is
you'll have this effect hidden
throughout all these other features in a
way you can't detect and it will also be
even if you knew it was there it'd be
much harder to fix so it's actually
important to keep the most offending
features in the model and then
afterwards see what was learned on them
and try to fix it okay now it turns out
these things are a good match for
homomorphic encryption so let's briefly
talk about that and then there's just
some other issues about using these
models where privacy is concerned so
let's first talk about homomorphic
encryption so this is a classic deep net
as you saw the demo that was using the
neural net was the one that ran the
longest and it turns out at least I'm
told the deeper your model is the more
expensive it is to do this sort of
homomorphic encryption it turns out the
kind of model we have this is our age
plot it's a number from this graph plus
a number from this but it's the opposite
of being deep right there's no deep here
this is this as a function of this which
is a function of this which is a
function of that all the way down this
thing is just give me a number plus a
number plus a number add them all up
right so this is the opposite of the
deep model and it turns out this is very
good for homomorphic encryption this is
our age plot
this is a second-degree polynomial that
Renny and I were able to fit to this
data and it turns out it's not a bad fit
for this now they ultimately went to
fourth degree polynomials because for
some of the other features you did need
a higher degree polynomial but by doing
polynomial fits to each of these terms
in the model they're actually able to
get something that's very performant
from a homomorphic point of view so that
good news to is by doing this they're
actually able to get a pretty high
flying model now it turns out it's
better than say random forests on this
data it's not quite as good as our model
or generalized additive model because
the polynomial fits aren't perfect but
it's actually a pretty good model so
it's a competitive model and then you're
able to do the homomorphic encryption
which is great so let's talk a little
bit just one slide about using these
models for privacy so you know imagine
you're one of a million patients who
gave your data to the hospital or to
some group to train this model and they
train this deep neural net and your
question is wow is my data hidden
somewhere in the hundred million weights
that are in this model you know you're
afraid your privacy is not being
preserved and somehow will leak out of
this model well the kind of model we're
training like looks like this right this
is our age graph again and you can kind
of look at these graphs the model is so
simple and transparent you can actually
kind of look at the graph and you can be
assured like you know maybe you know
your age is 80 and you can kind of look
at you say well hopefully I helped that
number be just right there but my gait
is not going to leak from this graph or
from some some of these graphs so so one
of the things that's nice about a model
class that's this simple is you can be
pretty assured that your personal data
can't leak out of it
whereas when you've got this complex
model on the left you actually don't
know if your personal data is somehow
encoded there in a way that might leak
in the future finally let's just talk
about one issue that that can arise here
so the beauty of these models is that
they're so simple we can actually read
them and understand them and even fix
them you know you know fix that sort of
thing and add a new feature stuff like
that
if however we're using this in a world
where we're talking a lot about privacy
and
encryption then the models kind of like
this right you can do the math some
magic thing comes out of here some
summation gets done but it is important
that a human somehow is able to check
these models so that they can fix things
that we we know are wrong
like the asthma effect heart disease
effect it's very important that we can
fix these things and if we fully hide
the model from everybody but if we can
do fully private homomorphic training of
the model on data that's also been
encrypted and if no human ever sees the
model then we have a problem because
transparency is actually necessary to
sort of trust the model and be able to
repair the model okay I think I won't
talk really about bias and transparency
I just want to say that the issues that
we're seeing for heart disease for
asthma these are exactly the same issues
that show up with race bias and gender
bias it's very important that you can
see the model so you can see how
racially or gender biased it is and then
you have a chance of being able to not
only see it but but to repair it just
just like repairing asthma so let me
jump through summary high accuracy on a
test set most of us would have thought
that this was enough that can be very
very misleading realize as we fix the
model remove the asthma remove heart
disease remove chest pain as we fix the
model the accuracy on the test data will
go down significantly and it should the
accuracy was always illusory and we only
knew that once we could see the model
very important lesson there are just
landmines hidden in almost all real data
in healthcare you've got to be using
something you can see correctness really
depends on what you're going to do with
it these models are working very well
deep learning is great but you know
sometimes you got to understand what's
going on inside the black box and it's
kind of nice that these models sort of
help us not only with privacy maybe
because they're so simple you can
understand what's going on but they also
seem to be a reasonably good match for
homomorphic encryption and I should stop
[Applause]
hi thank you very much for a great talk
use the word intelligible interpretable
transparent yeah and you kind of wave
the little finger at causal and it seems
to be like there's a big jump between
those first three words which I don't
know the definition of and causal which
seems to be the thing you're you're
striving for some curious if you could
talk about it's a great question great
observation and I remove the slide on
cause ality just because I didn't have
time for it why do I use intelligible
transparent and interpretable it's
because I don't know what they mean
either so I just want to sort of get
across this idea that we have a chance
of looking at the model trying to
understand it's not that the model is
correct and what it does for age is the
right thing if we move features around
remove features add features is those
terms will all change the only good
thing is we can completely understand
how the model makes its predictions it's
a completely wipe open box so we can see
what it's doing so that's all I mean by
interpretable or intelligible is that we
can at least understand how it's making
its predictions and of course in a very
high dimensional space you know ten
thousand features this would get
challenging as well these are not causal
models I think calls and modeling would
be the ultimate answer to all of these
things if we could do that accurately
from from observational data that's what
I would be working on it's just a very
hard problem and whether a causal model
could ever learn the sort of subtle
things that we're seeing for age and
other features from observational
samples of data I don't actually know
ultimately causality is what we're all
after we do have a hypothesis that the
simplicity of these model models means
that they sort of detect let's say the
signature of causal like things like I'm
the one who explained that that jump in
the graph at 65 66 67 was retirement it
could be something else I could be wrong
but it did seem to find something and
that something led us to try to figure
out what
was so we're the ones who are doing the
sort of causal analysis of what the
model has learned but your observation
is exactly right and this is this is no
more causal than a deep neuron that so
you mentioned about to this core way to
the features you give example three
features right mm-hmm so they remove
them you could find sorry
yeah some intelligible features but how
could you know that these three features
are not real features or they are until
you find other correlated features let's
see so the only thing we claimed yet
to be able to do is someone who has some
expertise like a doctor should be able
to look at how the models making its
predictions and should be able to notice
things they're like wow it thinks as
asthma is good for you heart disease
good for you chest pain is good for you
so we want a doctor to be able to
understand that the model is actually
like if you have a patient who has all
these other future values and then if we
suddenly make them asthmatic their risk
goes down and if we now also give them
heart disease their risk goes down
further and if they have a history of
chest pain their risk goes down even
further and a doctor presumably would
say well that might be a true statement
about the world given how we're
practicing health care but given that we
want to use the model to decide who to
admit to the hospital that's that's
broken we should not allow the model to
do that what a doctor might want to do
is zero out those terms which is just so
now the effect doesn't happen that
having asthma lowers your risk or a
doctor might even say well I want all
asthmatics and heart disease patients in
the hospital a plus 10 so so just just
make the risk oh through the roof so
that these guys will always get admitted
there's nothing magic about those
variables
it's just that presumably a health care
professional would recognize the model
is doing something stupid given our
intended use of the model and they would
want to investigate further why it's
doing that there's always a chance
asthma really was protective but they
don't believe that more likely they're
going to recognize oh it's a problem in
the data that's inappropriate given our
tended use and we just need to fix this
problem before releasing the model
otherwise we'll put asthmatics and heart
disease patients at higher risk so let
thanks again reach we have to go to the
next talk but which will be around thank
you reach I'll be around if anyone wants
to talk later
so last speaker for this session is a
Zhang Jian he was kind enough to come
all the way from CEO for us today
Joan he's a mathematician number
theorist cryptographer and he'll take us
to applications in different fields
other than health and genomics that we
talked about so far yeah Thank You Phil
introduction Ronnie it's my great honor
to keyboard talk in Microsoft Security
Summit today I introduce some more
applications of hope in patients
okay let's start with cars these days we
have more and more the smarter car so we
have this kind of news the hackers
remotely cure deep on the highway with
meaning so that's not the difficulty in
some sense
so just to turn on that dog scenario was
like this I turn on the tips radio and
then we write code embedded in the
entertainment system hardware and issue
commands to the internal network to
steering brakes and the engine looks
very dangerous so how to prevent these
attacks usually discotheques are
prevented some some security means but
no shequida mean can guarantee the
security of these are attacks against
the those attacks we have different one
subnet maybe all of most of all you
aware of these attacks in for SCADA
systems in 2010 the malicious control
entered computer system in the random in
each Minh facility some country so the
the metal was divided separate from the
internet but it they can enter fire we
guess
by your use memory sticks and then what
did the computer worms vary the
rotational speed of the centrifuges and
the destroy them so that is the the
wrong can control the data so how to
prevent the hacking this kind of CPS
cyber-physical systems also it
turned out to be very hard to prevent
malaria injections it's possible
sometimes but not always completely so
we have any other means to protect these
or none yet but we have some tools we
want to so that some tools for important
and small GPS systems we can use more
key coaches
okay so this is a basic the this is
basics of GPS systems scientifically
famous dust control system that is here
we have a plant you can consider smart
car or drones or SCADA systems to plant
heads or sensor and the sensor send on
send some information to controller the
controller computer typically typically
two kind of people solving differential
equations and then it outputs some
signal command to the actuator so to
secure these systems we can use some
encryption and the distancing later can
be is encrypted and go to goes to
controllers and control V click this one
and then we compute after computations
it encrypt again and send to the
actuator that
that it gets that's that's good but the
controller itself is not so secure that
is Mario ingestion can be done to
controller that is why controller
computing with some plain text the
murderer can manipulate this so simply
we using homo' pincushions we can do
this that is just computer incubator
without the creepy in the case are more
rare does not know the message inside
the ciphertext so he cannot control but
still he can make some errors but this
cyber-physical system is had their own
protection system so the usual actuator
can detect has a detection system so
some random knowledge can be detected
random shall change your book message
can be detected so you can prevent some
of those kind of attacks okay now you
can you tell more details in this paper
and yes like this the smart car for
example the sensor increase the data
with more pink region send the
controller controller compute without
ticketing and then send the increase the
command to the actuator but for those
encryption dodging that
yes I will talk about this yes I will
talk about it pretty straight I mean
okay so the it cannot completely prevent
the manipulation so the idea one is the
Wii U which we add authentication here
so that is we have homo quick
authenticated encryption it it the
controller compute on encrypt data put
preserving authenticity to so we can use
this one
so here the restriction is like this if
we don't have currently we don't have a
fully home fully hope you authenticate
the encryption but for any way we can do
and but it's a little bit a little
slower than home open question - so Oh
some we implement this on only linear
case so this is the our simulations so
fortunately we realized that the control
system is not so complicated in some
cases for example in turn cases that's
so complicated so the differential
equations can be converted into matrix
multiplications here so the objective
here is linear motor authenticated
inclusion is applied to test tracking
controller or drone for safe autonomous
flight we have four cases simply the
case one is not in cryptid nanotech case
to not increase but its effect that that
is more most interesting cases k2 is
increasingly not effect and in to
encrypt an detect let's see oh
yeah here you have doing it okay it's
like a small toy example they're not
encrypted not detecting categories here
the flying toward the desired
destination helipad
so we controlled very slowly because
it's expensive we know we cannot destroy
this one type and then yeah and so it's
a you know that its base the it it's the
attack of K control the drone it's very
dangerous
it can be a weapon like a missile and
then if we increase it not otech each
shape yeah flying for the destination as
it were and then but so it encrypted and
object and then it's easy
it takes an authentication property so
it can protect and then it can be
taunted or some some destination some
starting point or some other
destinations like this so we here we
used only linear model for this so for
more complicated model we need better
more efficient who will be authenticated
encryption but here we this demo shows
it it's possible yes with the the
current hardware okay let's move to all
big encryption and multi learning let me
explain who it is equation again here we
have two data we want to compute on
earth own input x and y C so here so
here is like a real world human world
here is a cyber world
that previously when we want to use this
computer to compute this one though we
need to give the plaintext or what we
eat with toward increased data here but
when we complete we have to Tikrit but
with more pink region blue is like a
type increased world actually the
ciphertext can be computed without
decreasing and then when we see that a
wizard its decrypted by this with the
secret key the critical key then the
result is the same with the computation
without encryption so we can think of we
can consider this idea to protect the
humans or just a eyes so we have this
kind of article so we have some fears on
AI and war but also the how to fit a a
while one possible consideration could
be we do not provide data to a eyes so
can we can we protect against the
dangers a eyes with whooping encryptions
nan yet still Aeneid it's pretty
difficult but we have some idea toward
safer AI and robot that is a cultural
system the protecting gps can be one
tools and another to is to keep the to
not provide data to AI that is we just
provide only encrypted data that is
let's consider this concept of profit
servant what is perfect servant
it does what do you want it but without
ever seeing my secret private data okay
so what do you mean we we can train AI
with encrypted data that is stored data
in public cloud app encrypt it and then
bosnian attacks increase the training
data as input it also includes matter as
in the slide of christian slide the the
Hoopoe encryption can do all the
computation motion the conductor can do
it it does tend up to what human can do
but it can follow all the computations
if the motion can do so the version we
can do machine learning or encrypted are
theoretically so this is the frame of
outline that is rotate in hope to most
learning load entice pre-processed by
our motivations to encrypt it to encrypt
this red ones ciphertext then in the
training phase we take input take these
encrypted data and input and then we
output increases model and this mass
increases model is applied to increase
the data to get incredible prediction
that is the model we are working on so
we have one example credit scores
so the it's very practical example the
the credits occur it can become more
accurate when using data from multiple
institutions for example look we can use
loan leaders from banks and we can use
phone bill and credit card payment and
youtube to build bills then we can add
we use more data from multiple studies
we have more accurate data but due to
privacy laws merging database from
different institutions or companies is
user prohibited not possible and then
that we can run most money on eclipse
credits course here the training 20 face
on encrypt data is kind of research
problem so you can find our paper by
christian in the five years ago but
still we are working on this but for
prediction phase we it's really faster
and we have alternate way as it it's
like this ok for same slide we can use
loan and beers include with open
captions and then training and
prediction we have another tools put
input predictions we have a functional
encryption that is what is functioning
creature in hope encryptions again when
we have a encryption of m1 and mm we can
compute increase of F of M and n m2 MN
for any function f for this function
equation with the same input we can
compute F over Eminem and play in plain
text poem when we are kidnapped but we
we have we should have some secret key
lead to take this app that is one
application or professional function
equation is like this when we are given
to increase the biometrics like M 1 and
M 2 if we want to check whether they are
the same we can use those hash functions
but in biometrics we have some knowledge
for input so we need to check if it's
similar to a man is similar to M 2 so
the it can be done with functional
encryption when given a cyclical similar
some specific secret key okay so the in
with the emotional earnings if the
prediction place is only its inner
product encryption that is for linear
model we can use functional encryption
that is input is like a week and then
private information is these vectors so
the the linear model for prediction
phase output a dot X inner product over
a and X then we can use in approaching
patient given a and encryption of X we
can compute FX when we have the secret
Odin a that is this secret the secret
can be sickly to that I mean that the
weight can be secret - okay and then we
have also some some skin texture in
Connemara in this in this case and then
it's thoroughly in a featured okay so we
can compare those analytics with other
means like practical proposals or key
anonymizing so I think the people we
have the data is more sensitive of
privacy with the better use more
penalties even though it's very it's not
so efficient in some case but the
crystal mentioned it can be efficient
for specific application especially if
we patch some cases and then if
complexity of all another function is
complicated hope integer is not so good
for this but we can improve the
efficiency but until that other methods
would be better for practical purpose if
is time let me conclude with introducing
hope what you know collection is that is
it's not so most of things actually this
is
than our sau some say in case let me
spell for three minutes
explain though what we hoped in
Christianese it's a symmetry setting
that is that we change the two primes P
and Q and then operation key public each
public is that P times Q inclusion is
very easy just take a modulo P and a
modulo Q here M is an integer between 0
and P Q U and V we know the decryption
is easy to use x remainder theorem to
recover em from this one and this one
it's it's product complexity the we know
the Bowden appeal Boudreaux Widow
consumer P with respect to origin and
even multiplication that is M 1 modulo P
and Q modulo P if we add it it's the
same with a month plus M 2 modulo P it
has more property only problem if this
king was proposed in 1978 only problem
is its nature it contained all the
functionality and very efficient what do
you mean if we have one plaintext and
ciphertext and the third difference is
the multi problem P so if we have
several pairs of plaintext and
ciphertext you can take yes we can take
a GCD to compute P so one great idea is
to use know each plaintext studies
instead of using old of it as a plain
text we add some knowledge here and then
we have very large sub we filled with
zeros for lots of positions then it
works thank you for attention
[Applause]
thank you very much we have time for a
couple of questions I want to take the
first question in your demonstrations of
in the cyber physical space yep is the
technology ready for application like
self-driving cars where you have high
throughput low latency kind of setting
or is there still some barriers in front
of us yes we need to improve more for
using more complicated real-time system
like a smart cards that's very
interesting application but we need to
develop more the second way to make much
thanks I also have a question on a smart
car example so you assume that the
control tents the encrypted data to the
Accu Tator who decrypt and then execute
the commands so then does the aggregator
then needs to have some piece of code
that executes the decryption and if
that's the case is it easier to just
hacked the a cuter than the controller
yes this is secret mod I have I should
have mentioned the secret matter in the
secret model we assume the engine or the
the plenty service feature so I
discussed this on with the expert in
this area control system state if we can
index some more way or some it can
contact the engine itself we have more
ways more to destroy them so it's
reasonable to assume the engine is safe
and then dot what the controller can be
a smart phone or some other GPO remotely
so yeah first time for one more question
thank you
when it comes to small cars do you think
there should be some level of minimum
security requirements before they're
allowed to be on the roads secretly
requirement when we using moving
Christians orders I do not know well you
put a smart car so we I heard that they
have lots of control system in there so
first we can try to apply this technique
to engine and I mean the brakes or so
accelerator but for security of the
smart car we need to discuss this on
with the expert in cars I think yes it's
just an easier step yeah there's one
more question whether it's actually just
a small comment you mention to a
different approach for obtaining private
machine learning techniques right
differential privacy and homomorphic
encryption we also have multi-party
competitions oh yeah yep Yuri I'm sorry
sometimes yeah
so actually the whole pink multi-party
computation can play similar rule with
competitions the difference is like
interactions yes I'm sorry
yeah okay let's thanks Joanne here again
yeah thank you very much and thank you
Oh to all the speakers that presented
here today and thank you all of you for
coming and joining us